- On this episode,
Kai Greene stops by.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey, everybody.
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 252
of The Ask Gary Vee Show.
I'm excited about this.
We got connected on
the DM, on Instagram.
We planned it.
And we made it happen.
- We are.
- Yeah.
Why don't you
tell the Vayner Nation
who you are and
what you do, my friend.
- What's up, everybody?
My name is Kai Greene,
aka Mr. Getting it Done.
I am a competitive
athlete
that had an opportunity to
step into a larger possibility.
Currently, we are
working on a number of projects.
And, with that I'm
an owner of a company,
Dynamic Muscles Supplements.
Acting, writing,
and I am in awe of being here.
(Gary laughs)
- The GaryVee Show.
- So Kai, why don't you
tell everybody a little bit,
let's take it
further back, right?
So, obviously
we've been promoting
that this is going to be on.
Do we have questions?
Are we live?
- [Andy] We're live.
- Yeah, good. Hey everybody.
- Wow, we're live.
- Live everywhere.
- Okay, okay.
- Are they
putting out phone numbers?
Is it Facebook?
- [Andy] Facebook.
- So Facebook, start
putting out you phone numbers
to get on the show
and ask Kai a question.
So, we've been promoting it,
you've been promoting it.
People have been really excited
about this collaboration,
which really is a lot of fun.
But, for a lot of the
audience that may not know,
your back story
all the way back,
tell me about
where were you born,
how'd you get so humongous?
(Kai laughs)
How did you get, how did you
become a competitive athlete,
and like, take me
back a little bit further.
- Okay. Well, you know
when I started out much--
- Where were you born?
- A lot of people.
I was born in Brooklyn.
- Love it. (laughs)
- Brooklyn, New York.
So, I'm a New Yorker.
- Yep.
- I'm a native New Yorker.
- You were always here?
You've always stayed here?
- I moved around a little bit,
but, I grew up in Brooklyn.
As we got older, we
kind of moved around.
- [Gary] Yep.
- Got a chance
to live out of state.
And currently we
spend a lot more time traveling,
so, abroad, so
we get a chance to,
because a lot of our
business is international.
We spend a lot
more time traveling.
But, yes I did
grow up in Brooklyn,
and I am
in the process of, hmm.
I'm trying to
answer this question.
(laughs) I grew up in Brooklyn,
born in Brooklyn.
- What kind of kid were you?
What were you into?
Were you into sports?
Were you like into video games?
Were you like quiet?
Did you read?
Like, what was your,
what was your jam,
let's call it,
first to seventh grade?
- Wow, first to
seventh grade I think,
I think we were set up
with a lot of challenges.
Originally, I was
a ward of the state.
So, I guess--
- [Gary] So, real
hard core challenges.
- As it, yeah,
could be imagined.
I think that
first to seventh grade
I think you spent a
large part of the time
just trying to become a
little bit better adjusted.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And, that was very
elusive, very, very elusive.
- And, you say "we."
You mean siblings?
- Yeah. You
know my brother and I
were, we were
wards of the state.
So, we kind of--
- At what age?
- I, hmm.
- Somewhere,
I would say around eight.
- [Gary] Uh-huh.
- Eight. So, we kind
of left home pretty young.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Pretty young.
But that's the
really interesting thing
about the story because
there was another time
when we probably
would've looked like
what would become
a negative statistic.
And definitely the
story wasn't a very easy one.
But it is a story that talk
about the path of becoming.
And, right now
I'm very, very excited
about the higher heights
that we've gotten a chance
to grow to and are still
in the process of growing.
- [Gary] Of course.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well, you're a young dude.
- Absolutely.
- And so,
what was the turning point
in your, in your younger age?
Like, when did
you get into body,
is it competitive body building?
- Yeah.
- I want to, I want to use
the right terminology here.
You know?
Did you get into exercise
and physical strength early on?
Was there a turning point?
Was there, was there,
when you say
a ward to the state,
like did you
have foster parents?
- Yeah.
- Like, what's that?
I want tomake sure--
- Yeah. Yeah, so
what happens is you have,
there are probably thousands
of young people right now
- [Gary] Sure.
- that, for one
reason or another,
find themselves in a situation
where their parents aren't
able to take care of them.
- [Gary] Sure.
- And in a
situation like that,
then the state--
- [Gary] Yep.
- Steps in, and,
either by force or, you know.
- [Gary] Sure.
- They step in and
they offer these services.
And, you'll have
a bunch of places,
either through like
the Catholic Church,
or various other kinds of...
- Institutions?
- They'll have institutions,
but they can be run
by any number of,
it's very interesting
because it's kind of not
something that I really do
a lot of thinking
about in the present.
More in the present
now, we think about,
you know, managing the company.
- [Gary] Sure.
- We think about
developing your career.
We think about focusing on um,
so this is very interesting.
(laughs)
- Very interesting walk.
- You know, it's interesting.
I think, I think
a lot of the future
is told by the past, right?
Like listen, I'm
not looking to pry.
Like, if that's
a chapter that you
wanted to close
the book on, and you're
focusing forward,
I want to be empathetic
because I don't
have that context.
But, I do think it's interesting
because I think it builds,
it speaks to the foundation.
To me, you know,
entrepreneurship,
building brands,
some of the stuff,
the businesses you guys
are building through, I believe
the ones that grow
up with more adversity
are far more
positioned for success
because, you know,
I'm sure you've figured out,
and I'm sure your
crew's figured out,
like all it is is adversity.
Like, you've got
a lot of awareness
and you've
built a big community.
So, obviously
there's a lot of opportunity.
However, business is hard.
Like, you know,
like it's way harder
than people think it is, and--
- Definitely that.
- And, whatever
new product or service
that you guys launch, truth is
nobody gives a fuck, right?
Like, just because you
were successful out there,
when I started a
social media agency,
everybody made fun of me.
They're like, "Wine
boy, stay in your lane.
"Like, what are
you doing?" Right?
So like, being
successful in one genre,
you know, there's, you're
met with a lot of cynicism
when you go into
different places.
Have you thought about that?
- Oh, in the
past what I would do
is play my cards
very close to my chest.
The first
thing I think when,
and I still think
it's very important
when you have some
goals and ideas that are big,
sometimes they may be too large
for the current capacity at
which you're willing to work.
You know, which means
you're going to have to
do some growing
in an effort to even
be able to
stand in that reality.
But, more importantly,
when you start to talk
about sharing it
with other people,
sometimes you
might need to keep it
close to your
chest because they won't
be willing to accept it.
And, the first thing they'll do
is discourage you.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- You know.
- That's an interesting insight.
You know, it's been funny.
That's a very
interesting insight,
and I'm going to
jump in here for a second.
I think it's so funny
that there's two paths.
And, so often there's two
paths, right? The two paths.
That is such an interesting
way of looking at it.
I'm funny. I go the other way.
I put my shit out
there so aggressively
because I actually need people
to tell me that I can't.
I'm the reverse.
When people, you
know, it's so funny.
I had somebody come
up to me not too long ago
who was like,
"Hey, man," you know,
"Oh my god," you
know, "Can I talk?"
And, I was like, "Sure."
And, we started
talking for a second.
He's like,
"I've got to just tell you,
"I hated you at first."
And, I was like, and he's like,
"And, what really
sucked was after a while
"I realized me
leaving negative comments."
He's like,
"I've got to be honest,
"like,
I left negative comments."
And then he's like,
"And then some video I saw,
"and I could tell
that you liked it,
"that I was
leaving negative comments.
"And that really fucked with me,
"because then I was
like now what do I do?"
And, so like, it's
interesting that, like there's,
like for me,
I need to put stuff out
because I feed
off of the cynicism
and the people chipping at it.
And then, I have a lot of
friends who keep it close,
and there mold is
to like, keep it there.
And then, it's just an
interesting psychology.
- Well, you know,
as a bodybuilder--
- [Gary] Yes.
- I think one of
the interesting things
about the subculture
is that I learned to
work in silence.
You know, you kind of,
you kind of become a hermit.
You go into the
underground, and you kind of
put your body of work together.
And then, the day
of the competition,
you unveil it, you know.
A lot of times, people
will talk a very good game.
I think most people have not yet
really mastered the ability to
be a Muhammad Ali, so to speak.
You know, talk a good game,
but still stay
very focused on creating
the desired end result
that they're looking for.
Some people get distracted,
and in a sense,
distract themselves.
I'd rather,
just because of the way
I was socialized
in my subculture,
to do it--
- [Gary] Kind of like that.
- That way. I put
my hood on, and I work.
I can show you
better than I can tell you.
- I understand.
- You know, and a
lot of times what happens is
the body of work
will speak for itself.
- Hundred percent.
Results speak. Kai, like--
- Absolutely.
- Like, you know my crew,
when you said Muhammad Ali,
a couple of us
looked at each other
because I think, I mean
it's an audacious thing,
but I love the idea
that I talk a big game.
I need it to then,
there's nothing better.
We put on a pedestal the people
that talk the biggest game,
and are able to actually--
- Yeah, mhmmm.
- Deliver. And
then we don't even know
the people who talk the big
game and couldn't deliver.
We don't even
remember who they were, right?
So, I think, I think
that's an interesting insight,
and I gree with it.
Andy, let's get us a question.
So, what else are you,
what are you, in specifics,
what are you most
excited about right now?
- Right now I'm
excited about being here.
(Gary laughs)
This is what's up.
- [Gary] You're keeping it--
- You know.
- [Gary] You're
keeping it very focused.
- Very, very focused.
You know, currently
we're working on
a bunch of projects.
One which is
very, very big for us,
even in my subculture,
is the new release
of Generation Iron 2.
It's, it's the second film,
where we get a chance
to present, for the subculture,
everybody in a, in
a spotlight of working
towards the
achievement of their goal.
And, not
necessarily just focused
around winning a title or show,
but actually
stepping out into life
and aiming to be successful in--
- That's cool.
When's that come out?
- Well, it comes out in May.
- Nice.
- We're actually going
to Body Power next weekend,
next week actually, to set
up the premiere in the UK.
- Nice.
- Yeah.
- Love it. Got it?
- [Andy] Dylan from Albuquerque.
- Dylan.
- [Dylan] Hello?
- Dylan, it's GaryVee. You're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
with Kai. How are you?
- What's up, Dylan?
- [Dylan] Oh, shit. Oh.
- (laughs)
How's it going, Dylan?
- [Dylan] I was just
watching the live stream
like five minutes ago.
- And now you're on the show.
- [Dylan] (laughs)
Hey, and Kai Greene,
shout out to you, too, man.
I used to see you
in magazines and shit.
Like, you were
pretty dope, man. (laughs)
- So, what's your
question, my friend?
- [Dylan] Hey so,
I wanted to ask you
about time management
with entrepreneurship,
like your daily routines,
that kind of thing.
So, I'm managing,
well we have like
a digital marketing agency that
between the marketing,
and the whole crop,
scraping all the sales stuff.
Like, what would you
say is your best advice
on managing daily
routines, time management.
- Kai, how do
you think about your
time management
and your daily routine?
- (laughs) Well, I think
one thing you might
want to think about doing
is, aiming to be early.
I think if you're very
effective aiming to be early,
you're least likely to be late.
(Gary laughs)
- [Dylan] Yeah.
- That is absolutely true.
- (laughs) Absolutely.
But, then also being clear
about what your priorities are.
'Cause they're,
any time we set ourselves up
for a schedule, we may find
that other things may come up.
And there always
are going to be things
that will pull at
your concentration.
And, I think the more successful
you become with
managing yourself,
you become more
attractive, which means
that more things will
pull at your concentration.
- I think you've
got to make your actions
back up your ambition, right?
Like, my process is very simple,
which is I've talked a big game,
I have a lot of
wants and dreams,
and my schedule today needs
to map my big fucking mouth.
Right? Like, that's it.
And so, you know, one thing
that shocks people
when they get close,
I remember when
Tyler first filmed,
when Justin first filmed,
Iris, when you get to film,
the biggest thing
you're going to know
is like, wait a minute.
It's every second.
It's actually every second.
- [Dylan] Yeah.
- Like it's, you know, like--
- I think time is the asset.
And so, the one
thing I would tell you is
as you're prospecting, as
you're trying to get sales,
you've also got to
deliver on your work.
If you've got an agency, like
selling is just the beginning.
- [Dylan] Well, yeah.
- Selling is set like,
everybody's so
focused on selling,
but a lot of
people starting these
small social media
agencies just to get clients.
They forget that
after you get the clients
you've got to fucking deliver.
Keeping business--
- [Dylan] Yeah. (laughs)
- Keeping
business is what actually
builds big businesses,
not getting new business.
- [Dylan] Yeah.
Yeah, definitely. So--
- I would, I would--
- [Dylan] Keeping,
keeping business.
- I would add to
the process to make sure
you're talking to
your current customers,
not just trying
to find new ones.
- [Dylan] Yeah.
- Cool, man. Thank you.
All right. Let's keep going.
- That's good advice.
- You like that?
- I love that.
- I think farming,
so hunting is very attractive.
Right? Like it's no
different, kind of, than,
it's a little
version of what you said,
which is let the actions
speak instead of the words.
It's how I think about business.
I'm a big talker, but
from a business standpoint,
people see me in
my sales and all this,
but it's the farming.
It's the retaining clients.
It's the meetings.
- Maintenance.
- It's the maintenance.
It's the maintenance.
- Yeah,
acquisition is one thing--
- Hundred percent.
- But yeah,
maintenance. I get it.
- Who's this?
- [Andy] Scott.
- Scott?
(phone ringing)
- Let's see if
Scott comes through.
- [Scott] Hey, it's Scott Lara
from Jacksonville, Florida.
Is this The GaryVee Show?
- It sure is, Scott.
And you're on
with Kai Greene. How are you?
- Mr. Personality.
- [Scott] Gary,
gentlemen, it is an honor.
Gary, I'll tell you something,
Crush It! changed my life.
I appreciate it.
And, the one thing
I love about you, Gary,
is you engage
with your followers,
and I thank you for that.
- [Gary] My pleasure.
- [Scott] The number one
question, yeah, thank you,
and the number one
question I have for Kai
is when you wake
up in the morning,
and you don't feel
like going to the gym,
how deep do you have to go down
and say, "I've got to do this?"
- I think,
I think it varies.
I think there's some mornings--
- [Gary] Do you go
to the gym every day?
- Yes. Yes.
- [Gary] Multiple times?
- [Gary] Yeah.
This is what you do.
- But, I mean, also my
ambition was to be the best
in my craft, the best
in my field, the best--
- And, is that Mr. Olympia?
Like, is that,
like what that is considered?
- Well, it was. It was.
- It's not as much anymore?
- Now, um--
- I like watching
your team react to this,
because I don't have,
I don't have the subtext.
So I'm like, "Oh,
what are they saying,
"like what's happening?"
- See, because--
- I'm getting excited.
I'm like, "Ooh, I've got
"to Google some shit
after this interview."
- [Man] Yes, yes.
(Gary laughs)
- It's always
the promotion thing.
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah.
- You know, that,
that we're definitely
not trying to indirectly do.
- [Gary] Sure.
- To say that there
was a time when, you know,
to be the best
athlete in the world,
meant that we had to get up
and follow a certain protocol.
- [Gary] I get it.
- Is the most important way
that I would like to
answer that question.
- [Gary] Please.
- And, even, even now, whether
it is the Mr. Universe,
whether it's, you know,
whatever said championship
or not, reality is that
in order to be the best,
you know, you have
to be willing to give
a certain amount
of your concentration
and your time,
dutifully, every day
to make that a reality.
- Do you struggle
to go to the gym?
What's his name?
- [Andy] Scott.
- Scott, Scott.
- [Scott] Yes. Yes,
I do, actually, guys.
Because, you know,
I'm 55 years old,
I, you know,
I want to look good.
I want to stay healthy.
And, Gary, you
inspired me to do that
because I see you
out there all the time,
and you are moving.
And, I think when
people just sit around all day,
they become sedentary.
Then you lose the battle.
So, yeah, I go
to Planet Fitness,
here in Jacksonville,
three times a week to stay fit,
not only for me and my wife--
- Nice plug.
- [Scott] But for my
upcoming grandchildren.
- (laughs) I love that, man.
I think that's great.
My answer is that Jordan just
keeps texting me
until I get out of bed.
That's my move.
(Scott laughs)
- Scott, thanks
for watching the show.
- I will say this.
- [Gary] Please.
- I wanted to
throw this at you, Scott,
or anyone else that's
listening--
- [Gary] Oh, so he
can listen to that.
Let's get the next question.
- Is a lot
of that is really
about remembering
what is important,
being able to be in
touch with your "why."
- [Gary] Yep, yep,
- A lot of people
have heard that stuff,
but, you know,
I think whether you're
the professional athlete
or you're--
- [Gary] Or you want to be
in good shape for your mate.
- The person that's
saying, "Hey, I want to
"be in good health. I want
to be in good shape.
"This is what I need to do."
I think that you're
more likely to lose focus,
or more likely to want to
stay in the bed and not go,
when you are not
looking at the end result
that you're looking for.
- [Gary] Hundred percent.
- You know.
- You know, when did you
start working out for real?
- I started training
when I was like nine.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Jesus.
- I turned
professional before I was,
before I reached
my 21st birthday.
- Nine, Andy.
(phone ringing)
Come on Andy.
You haven't
worked out in nine days.
This guy started
working out when he was nine.
(laughing) I know.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
Who's this?
- [Andy] Kinyoh.
- Hey it's GaryVee
and you're on The #AskGaryVee
Show with Kai Greene.
Who's this and where you from?
- [Kinyoh] Oh man,
this is super crazy.
My name is Kinyoh.
I really didn't think this
was going to happen at all.
My name is Kinyoh, I'm from...
- Well you dialed. You put
Yo K, you put your phone number
in the stream.
I mean you had to
think it had a chance
of happening.
- [Kinyoh] Yeah,
(Gary laughing)
but there are like 300,
500 numbers though.
- Well, where
are you from my man?
- [Kinyoh] I'm from San Antonio.
- Love it.
What can we do for you?
- [Kinyoh] My question,
the one that I put in there.
I've been growing
an advertising agency
called Project Forward.
- Okay.
- [Kinyoh] And I was
wondering how do you find out
how big of a
client you should go for?
I just started.
I have three meetings this week.
- Nice.
- [Kinyoh] And while I
started like a year ago,
but I just got to the point
where I have clients.
- You're getting serious.
Nice.
- [Kinyoh] So yeah.
So I have three
meetings this week.
Even if I close all of them,
I'll still like,
they're very small.
So I'm wondering
how do you find out
how big of clients
you should go for and--
- Well the answer
is you should go for
the biggest clients you
can possibly get, right?
You should go for
Apple and BMW.
What I think you're
self-aware enough to know is
that they're not
going to hire you.
So I think--
- [Kinyoh] Right.
- I think what you need to do is
stretch your ambitions
and stay practical
at the same time.
So I think what I just heard is
I would have
loved for you to have
five meetings or two meetings
of the way the three looked
and then one is a stretch goal.
Right? I think
you should always ask.
Sliding into DMs,
writing emails,
putting out content
that's a gateway to the agency.
I think it's super important.
What I did with VaynerMedia
to give an example
is we started off and
it was like $3,000 a month.
And then people said yes.
And the next meeting,
no matter what
it was $4,000 a month.
I just kept going until
it became $15,000 a month.
Some said yes.
- [Kinyoh] Right (laughs).
- Some said no.
But I remember when I
was at $11,000 a month.
There was seven or
eight meetings in a row
that were noes.
And I was like
I didn't feel like
I should've went backwards.
I still felt confident.
I felt like 11 wasn't enough.
Maybe 150
but not 11.
And I hear
people emailing me like
"Gary I'm really struggling."
"I don't think it's working."
"I think I have a bad idea."
And I reply.
They're like, "I did
some sales meetings
"that they didn't go well."
I'm like, "How
many have you done?"
They're like, "Two."
(Kai Greene hums)
And I'm like, let
me get this straight.
You've done two sales calls
sales meetings
and they didn't go well
and you're
questioning your entire shit?
Right Kai, you know
some days don't
good in the gym, right?
It didn't go as
well as you want it to.
- Right.
- It didn't click.
You know, but so I would say
it's not about knowing
how big you should go for.
It's that you should try to go
for as big as you can.
Then you service it
and if you can see that
they're satisfied with it
now you have proof of concept
that there's
somebody in the world
that's willing to
pay you $6,000 a month
and they're happy about it.
Which then means,
you have the potential
to have a lot more people
that are willing to do that.
Understand?
- [Kinyoh] Awesome. Yes.
So how did you figure
out that first number though?
That first $3,000.
- I made it up.
- [Kinyoh] Okay. (laughs)
- I was like
- [Kinyoh] Right.
Well, $3,000 sounds right.
I fucking made it up.
(laughing)
- [Kinyoh] Right.
- You know?
How'd you come up
with your first number?
- [Kinyoh] The first
person offered it to me
and I was like
oh, that's way more
than I was expecting.
(laughing)
So I'm going to keep
going with that (laughs).
- My man, that's how so
many businesses have started.
The way I started speaking.
How much did I want?
I made it up
and then it was too little
and I made up more
and it was still too little.
You just go through it.
It's called,
stick with me here,
experience.
Experience matters.
All these youngsters
that are super talented,
Dunk!
He's so talented and young.
He fucking sleeps on experience.
Wait until he
actually adds experience.
Then he's going
to be a real ninja.
Experience matters.
It's how you learn.
You go through the battles.
You're like, "Oh shit.
That's how it happens."
"Oh, I didn't know."
Experience is real.
I thought I was unstoppable
at 23.
And I was.
I built a huge business.
But guess what?
41-year-old Gary will
destroy 23-year-old Gary.
In within one round.
It's just experience.
It's real.
Got it?
- [Kinyoh] Right. Yeah.
- Cool.
- [Kinyoh] I love your
confidence by the way.
- Thank you.
- [Kinyoh] I don't actually
know who's on the show today.
- Kai is.
- But I bet they're awesome.
- Kai Greene. Check him.
- Awesome.
- Follow him.
- I'm going to check him out.
- And you're gonna
have big fucking muscles.
Alright, see ya.
(group laughter)
Now Kai, one thing I noticed
as we've been prepping for this
through social
is kids freak out
when they see you.
I was really enjoying seeing.
That must feel amazing.
- Ummmm.
Well you know what?
It's one of those things
where I don't think
that I spend a lot of time
focusing on how I feel
because much like the caller
that we had a
little bit earlier.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- How do you respond
when you don't feel like?
And most often then not,
my feelings, I feel,
will betray me.
You know?
- [Gary] Interesting.
- So I try not to
rely on my feelings
and just try to be
more consciously aware
of the things that
I want and my thoughts
and allow my
thoughts to lead me.
Recognize that I need to be able
to control my thinking,
so when I feel things
that are telling me,
that usually is an indicator
that I'm not focused
where I need to be
in order to make
this thing easier.
- I'm gonna jump
on that in a minute.
It's GaryVee, you're
on The #AskGaryVee Show.
Who's this and
where are you from?
- [Brian] Gary,
this is Brian Cronon.
- Brian, how are ya?
- [Brian] I'm from Nashville.
Doing good man, how about you?
- Good, say hello to Kai.
- [Brian] Kai, what's up man?
- How you doing, sir?
- [Brian] I'm doing good,
I actually just watched
the documentary on you
not too long ago on Netflix,
with Mr. Olympia.
- Thank you.
- [Brian] Very impressive.
- How'd you
feel about that, Kai?
I'm just kidding,
I'm just kidding.
Alright, what's
your question, my man?
- [Brian] So I've
got this client of mine,
I've been running kind of a
social media for his business,
he has a few gyms
here in the Nashville area.
He's a body builder, he's
won Mr. Tennessee I believe,
once or twice.
And now he's come
to me and is asking,
you know, Brian, how do
I take my accomplishments
and my personal brand
and take it to the next level
so I can monetize that?
How do I grow that?
You know, do I
grow my social larger?
Start, you know, looking for
sponsors, selling supplements,
so on and so forth.
- What does he want
to push that towards?
Is the
accomplishment just financial?
Which is super fine.
- [Brian] Money.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
he's gotta pick the things
that he wants to draw.
The answer is you need
to bring value to people
so they follow you, and then
you decide what you want to
move your audience to
and you need to believe
in what you sell, right?
Like, just getting, you know,
I remember I was visceral
against supplements
over the last decade
because the first
80 people I met, I knew didn't
give a fuck about what
was in the supplements,
they were just
slapping some label on some
shit they bought in China,
and so I was like.
And I remember
thinking, shit this is scary.
These are like
friends or acquaintances.
I was like, bro, what if like
in four years it's found out
that you don't even
know what you're buying!
What if people die from cancer,
like how could
you live like this?
So I was just like
completely like, you know,
now I've become a
little more educated,
started getting
my fitness better,
I've started meeting
people that are actually
from the fitness
game and care about it,
and like do the homework.
I mean Jordan is so
unbelievably knowledgeable,
like the way he talks
about stuff it's thoughtful.
It's thoughtful.
It's not slapping a private
label on the cheapest pills
in bulk they could buy
in Alibaba and trying to
flip them on
your Twitter account.
So I think the answer
is very simple, my man.
He needs to
bring value to people,
and you can only do so much,
because he has to bring value.
It's not that you
can manipulate that.
- [Brian] Sure.
- And then he needs to
decide what he wants to
push that audience to, and he
needs to feel good about it.
So if he feels good that his
gym is worth $299 a month,
like the reason it's so
easy for me to sell books,
is I just think it's really
worth $14 fucking dollars.
Like, you know you gotta feel
good about what you sell.
So I would tell you, you
need to get serious with him,
and not have a surface
level conversation with him.
You need to stress
test the relationship,
and put him in a position
that he has to understand
that he has to first
bring value to people
on social, and then he needs
to push them towards something
he really believes in.
And that takes time, not,
"Hey Brian, get my social up,
"so we can make some money."
- [Brian] Yeah.
And do you think, and
maybe Kai you can answer
towards this, is there
a social media platform
that you would want
him to focus more of his
time and attention
on for that wealth?
- Kai, what's
your thoughts on that?
- Well to echo
what you said about taking
the developing,
giving something in use value
that you can believe in.
You can, I guess, you know
Facebook would be really cool,
but you could go on and
develop a YouTube channel,
and give some really
good practical advice
that starts to talk
about helping people overcome
or deal with some of the issues
that they're wrestling with.
Maybe you can think about
speaking to a unique market.
There are a lot of
people that are dealing with
a host of issues
that diet or
different dieting strategies
can help, not just talking
about the Mr. or Mrs. Jones
that wants to
lose a few dress sizes,
but the person that
actually needs to eat
in a specific way to
combat some of the health crises
that they find.
And as a result, aren't as
easy, or find it not as easy
to find those answers
you know, just out there.
I think you could
develop a resource
that speaks to
that specific group,
or a bunch of different needs,
and now create something
of a substantial use value
that is worth the
subscription price
on your, or actually
technically more than that.
So you give more in
use value than the actual
dollar figure that you charge.
- Tried and true advice, man.
Provide people value up front,
then sell them something
you believe in.
Super simple.
- [Brian] Cool.
- Yep.
And by the way, to
answer your question,
Instagram, Facebook, YouTube.
Snapchat and Twitter are
the next tier below that.
But the three things
above that, priority.
Can't win in 2017
without a substantial
Instagram, Facebook,
and YouTube strategy.
Can't win.
- [Brian] Got it.
- And that's on video.
And so then if you
want to talk about written,
Medium, LinkedIn, your own blog.
And then if you
want to talk about audio,
your own podcast,
other people's podcasts,
Spotify, believe it or not.
Soundcloud, believe it or not.
Content on music platforms,
I think is an arbitrage.
Got it?
- [Brian] Cool.
- Cool.
- [Brian] Awesome, man.
- Thanks.
- [Brian] I appreciate it
and go Jets!
- Yes, go Jets is right.
Kai, I really
appreciate you man.
- Oh, likewise.
- Yeah thanks for
being on the show.
What's the question of the day?
You get to ask the
whole Vayner Nation
any question you want.
Good opportunity for
you and your team to get
two or 3,000 answers
across Facebook and YouTube,
of maybe some insight,
some trends, something you're
curious about what
the masses are thinking.
Question of the day,
could be something funny like
what's your favorite root beer?
Like, question of the day, go!
- Well, um, hmm.
Will Kai answer this
question directly or not?
That's a joke.
(Gary laughs)
- I saw some of that
come through on social.
- Um, wow.
You know I really don't have one
right off the top of my head,
a question of the day.
- Are you ever
curious about, in your world,
what are some of the
themes that people are
talking about or thinking about?
- In my world, I'm thinking
about improving my game.
In my world, I'm thinking about,
I mean everyone
wants to ask questions
that are minutiae.
Well, how many grams of
protein, how many grams of fat?
- Right, right.
- How much--
- The commodity shit.
- That's, you know--
- The stuff that doesn't matter.
- Recognizing
that I am in control,
you know, I decide
what's gonna happen, or not.
You know, I can plan
effectively or ineffectively.
I can stand in my own way,
or become my own most
powerful ally.
So I guess maybe the
question of the day is,
who are you?
Who are you willing to be?
Yeah.
- I love that.
I appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)